[Music]
let's go to janelle in seattle what's up
janelle
hello dr john how are you i'm good how
are you
good
good i um i guess i i have a question um
i'll just start out um i i feel like my
husband and i are never on a team
um i i want to respect him and um and
his personality but i just i can't get
past the irresponsibility and the weight
he has me carry
um and i just i just don't know how to
deal with it it's been like eight years
and it just seems like we just can't
get on the same page i don't know what
to do oh man i'm sorry
like just before we even dig in
like that's a
that's hard huh
yeah
yeah and and we've we've
talked about it argued about it um like
financially i've done the every dollar
app i have it all done all he has to do
is look at it and tell me where i
overspent
and he just he just doesn't care and i
just i just don't know what to do about
him like please tell me like to stop
spending or something you know just have
an opinion and he just
he just doesn't so it's so they gave me
some notes on this jenna gave me some
notes um
says that y'all have been through
bankruptcy together
tell me about having to buy a house from
your parents
yeah yeah so um
when we got married it was like three
months after
um we got married i got hit with um
he told me that
he owed
like
tons of money to the irs
how much and i didn't
like
70 000. okay
and his mother was doing his books
and so
his books weren't very
well
done you know and so we did a refinance
on his house
and
i really didn't want to do it but i felt
like well we're married so
we i kind of had to
um
then he had a business on his own and
found out that his business partner was
stealing money from him like ten
thousand dollars and the only reason we
found out is because i said you need to
go through
the books and make sure everything is
done
then
he
he ended up
he was drinking
a lot and so
um
i felt like i needed to move closer to
family
and so
after bankruptcy which
i was pretty devastated because
i don't
like that's not how i am yeah you know
what i mean so it was pretty
embarrassing and then we bought a house
um from my parents and um
it just
it just feels like my whole life is
based off of
his
decisions
and i just feel like i'm constantly
coping you know what i mean that you're
that you're getting dragged around
aimlessly
right so when you all have these
conversations he just blows him off
he gets really defensive
yeah and he um is really extreme and
then he like he'll say i'll just take
over everything and we'll just
move you know in to another state and
you know we have kids so i'm not going
to drag them all through
this but so i'm trying to keep it stable
for your kids are getting dragged
through it
yeah there is no protecting them from
this they're absorbing every second of
it
i know and it's and it's hard yeah oh
yeah yeah no i know it's hard
um the als will stay together for them
or
um
my husband's an alcoholic he cheats on
me he's abusive he doesn't come home
he's bankrupt us he's not
but the kids
right
yeah
they can often become a proxy for making
hard decisions or they become an excuse
for making hard decisions
right
um
have you and your husband sat down and
talked about divorce separate now
um there have been conversations um
we've gone to marriage counseling
um and it seems like
he's
it's only when it's it's only if i get
upset
that i'm taken seriously
um he he has right now he has a great
job and um we're financially okay now i
just feel like
um he still has me
carry these those bricks you know in the
backpack when you say you've got to
carry stuff
what are you oh yeah what you what are
you being forced to carry
um the finances i take care of all of
the bills um what happens if you say i'm
gonna stop
they won't get paid
okay
so you you are married to a child
yeah okay
do you feel much the words you're using
sound much more maternal like you're his
mother
yeah
and whenever i and this is a super
common thing so i want you to feel like
you're on an island by yourself but when
one or the other
spouse takes on more of a parental role
there's a different intimacy there
nobody wants to sleep with their son and
nobody wants to hook up with their mom
right so there's a it
it has a glitch in that relationship
and then
um that intimacy ripples through every
right so it just becomes a domino that
falls
um
have you when you've sat down with him
before i know you've probably had a
million conversations
uh what does he say about like
i don't want to be your mom anymore
he gets defensive
what does that mean
um
because that's what children do they get
mad they spit they throw things they
kick things yeah it's it's it's it's
pretty much slamming doors um
yelling you know um just about how he
can't do anything right and
it's a child response
yeah yeah i guess so
um
it is it's grown up timber tantrum i'm
taking my ball and going home
fine we'll just move and we'll never
come shut up like right that's i mean as
a child
i need a grown-up to sit down across the
table with me and say are you gonna do
marriage with me anymore
yeah are we gonna protect our kids
right
are we going to
ever um
fix the
sexual intimacy issues in our marriage
are we ever gonna have some kind of firm
financial footing where we're on the
same page and we're on the same team
right you see what i'm saying like right
um that's a different
yeah it's hard it's hard to be married
to a child it's really hard to be
married to temper tantrums
and my guess is if he was on the phone
with me
um
he could probably point back to a few
places in his life when
a child had to take over and start
defending him from things
oh yeah sure and that child still
playing defense for him and so that
child kept him alive at one point kept
him safe at one point and now that child
is destroying everything around him
right
yeah
and so the question is
is there a way that you can communicate
with him
have you sat down ever and said i need
like
normally when i talk to couples in this
situation the the conversations the deep
talks always happen on during fights
yeah
and
it feels like a great moment when his
finances are secure he's got a good job
things are okay to circle back and say
we need to have a big
we need to have a couple of hard
conversations
um i'd like to plan a half day would he
do that with you
he he would um
i think it's for me it's the follow-up
you know like you said you were gonna do
like i've asked him like can we please
go over the finances once a month like
the beginning of the month please and
the every dollar is already done you can
see where all the money is spent and we
need to go over but you see you see
that's i would say that's one of the big
challenges because you've made every
dollar a math problem
yeah it's a different conversation to
say i don't feel safe
yeah i've told him that i feel
completely and totally alone without you
and when you don't participate it's
i can do the budget i'm a grown woman i
i can pay our bills
i feel like you would rather kick and
scream and throw a temper tantrum
than help your wife feel safe
yeah
that's a totally different conversation
and if he doesn't respond to that which
some
some marriage partners don't oh get over
yourself it's just a stupid budget
then the next response is i have to make
decisions about do i want to be married
to somebody who's not going to
participate in my marriage
right
because really you feel dragged around
it's the other way around you're
dragging him around
and i think you're tired
of carrying somebody in addition to your
kids in addition to your own things
um and you're probably by carrying him
probably carrying his family around and
all that other drama and you've got the
shame that you're carrying around but
all that you're tired
i am it is it's tired and there's just
it just seems like there's so much
outside
drama that it's just that's right yeah
yeah and so a lot of this gets put on
um
on him
and he's a huge contributor make no
mistake
but my guess is there's a lot of just
mess
right there's just stuff
and so i think a valuable exercise would
be to sit down and say all right i'm
going to write this stuff down what is
really on me
and you might find out that it's his
brother that comes over every wednesday
that always you know
like whatever like who knows what all
the things are once you start writing
them down but i'm gonna write these
things down
and you have to come up with your or
what statement and
an or what statement is couples who have
reached a point where like we need to
decide if we're going to stay married or
not we're going to have to decide if
we're going to keep dating or not
if these things don't change the or what
is then i'm going to go
or if you know in your heart and mind i
will never leave i'm never gonna leave
then the alternative is to make peace
with where we are
and
there is a
often a blending of the two here's an
example in my own home okay
uh talk about this a little bit on the
show i'm i'm a mess
i
have uh
i'm just kind of all over the place
and my wife is very list makey and very
untimely
and
um very like things got to be done in
this way
and
i i
i've tried i can't operate in the world
that way
and
i also know that
putting my shoes away
is a sign to my wife that i love her and
value her
yeah and so here's a compromise i got
home at 4 00 am the other day i didn't
unpack
i opened up my suitcase grabbed some
underwear out jumped in the shower and
got in bed and went to sleep i was
exhausted
okay you have no idea what it's like
trying to sleep on a plane next to kelly
who's listening to it her 80s medal
i'm just kidding she wasn't singing
but
so she walks in
at eight o'clock in the morning there's
a half open suitcase her stuff's thrown
everywhere
she's able to exhale and say
he got in late last night her first
thought is isn't
figures he's act like a child stupid
baby like her first thought is man he
must be exhausted
yeah and then when i got up and i
stumbled around got my coffee went out
and did my little weird morning routine
then i could immediately say what's the
best way i can honor my wife right now
i need to get this crap cleaned up you
see what i'm saying it's about how can i
meet your needs and how can i meet my
needs that's how we found some peace in
the middle there it's not either or in
her perfect world you get home at 4am
you unpack you put everything where it
goes you start a load of laundry then
you go to bed right and then you make up
your bed
my perfect day is i'll unpack in a few
weeks when i'm leaving in town again
right so we're gonna find peace in the
middle all that happens because i'm
committed to meeting her needs and she's
committed to meeting mine
yeah
and if you can't have that with a
partner you've got to decide am i in or
am i out
can i letters what is that what are the
effects on the kids
do you know what i mean
the kids need well parents
yeah
the kids need well parents
and you're not okay and your husband's
not okay
and so any sort of pseudo performance to
try to make them
the reason why
this chaos continues
the the times for me that we're staying
together for the kids works is if we're
staying together and we are so committed
to making this marriage thing work
yeah then a hundred percent figured out
yeah but when grenades are going off and
there's abuse in the home or there's
deception and infidelity and all these
things but we're standing together for
the kids
the kids are getting a ringside seat as
to what marriage and love look like
and they're getting a ringside seat to
what a beatdown exhausted mother looks
like
and a
lying deceiving
scheming husband looks like
or somebody who throws temper tantrums
oh that's what grown men do when someone
holds a mirror up to them they throw a
temper tantrum and they kick and scream
and take their ball and go
that's what they're getting
yeah
sometimes there's a gap and there's the
stay together or the divorce sometimes
uh terry reel talks about a 30 day
timeout
people are yelling and screaming 30 day
timeout
um and here's the he's actually got on
his website the rules of the 30-day
timeout
i gotta get some space right and i'm not
saying that's the right thing for you
guys i'm saying there's an option
between we're all out of here or we're
all right
um
at some point your husband's gonna have
to decide is he in or is he out yeah and
that's it it's gotten to the point where
we don't even
[Music]
like if we argue it's it's in our
bedroom and there's there's not a lot of
screaming except for like maybe once
every six months he might just go off
you know what i mean
um but it's i just feel more than
anything like you said just that beat
down like and that's that's some of that
comes from when you write down your
needs
one of the needs will be you will never
yell at me again
okay
you will never scream in this home
you will not raise your voice and kick
things in this house
and the moment y'all are in a
disagreement
every marriage has disagreements i had
one this morning every marriage has
disagreements
right
the moment a voice gets raised you can
say hold on hold on
i will not be talked to like that i will
be back later
you head out the door
yeah
and he can kick and scream and yell
knock your lights out brother i'm not
going to be in the presence of this
okay that's what a boundary is
and for most children
they bang their heads up against
boundaries to see if they hold
and okay if they don't hold they keep
pushing until they find something in
their life that holds firm
and so you've probably told them a
million times i'm not doing their bills
anymore and then
five days later you're like i gotta pay
the bills
yeah there was there was like one time i
said can you take this to the post
office
and it sat in the truck that's very
month
and the follow-up is you always let us
you never do this i always i just need
one thing or the other is
when you didn't drop this off
the story i told myself is you don't
care about me
you don't care about the safety of our
kids you don't care about us having a
water and
running water in our home
that's your behavior is a language and
your behavior told me you don't care
yeah
and it's not me yelling and screaming
that's that's me saying hey
here's what your behavior is telling me
and it makes me scared it makes me sad
and part of my
my values are i'm not going to be in
relationships that make me scared or sad
yeah
i get to choose that
yeah and any step forward with the child
if you say hey
this these things
i need you engaged at this level
um
or i'm i'm not interested in continuing
this relationship
a hundred percent expect the only
response that he seems to have which is
to act like a child
and oh you're gonna take my kids away
from me you're gonna take my
the same as if you tell your kids no you
cannot have fruity pebbles for dinner
again
oh you never let us do anything you're
the worst i hate you
it's a child response
and until your husband decides to
address the child who's been protecting
him his whole life
and to go back and deal with some of
that heavy trauma that he's experienced
i almost guarantee yes
and
come to terms with
um being a participant in his home
meaning he's a participant in his family
meaning he's a participant in his own
life
meaning he's worth being loved and he's
worth loving himself and he's worth
healing from some of that nonsense
and let me tell you it can happen i've
seen it happen it takes a lot of work
but it can happen it's hard
to be incredible until he does that
he's going to get back to a child
and children are really hard to be
married to we made laws and such
so sorry that you're exhausted i can
hear it on you i can hear it on you
we'll be thinking about you in your
journey
just try to
sit down and decide here's what i'm
worth here's what my values are here's
what i need in this relationship and
then have a conversation about what
that's going to look like moving forward
my hope is that he jumps and goes all in
says i hear you this time
let us know how that half day retreat
goes i'm fascinated to hear the
follow-up
and uh if he ever wants to tell him call
me i'd love to chat with him